our top story this hour parts of the
city of light are set Ablaze during
anti-government protests demonstrations
have turned violent ever since president
Emmanuel macron's unilateral decision to
raise France's retirement age by two
years Michael George is here with more
on the protest and the political
opposition to this bill good morning
Michael Michelle good morning the French
president has risked everything to force
pension reform he says without it the
system will go into deficit but that
decision has led to anger and protests
across France thousands are now taking
to the streets
fighting on Paris streets is over
something French workers there cherish
the country's Social Security retirement
system that provides yearly pension
benefits as much as 50 percent of their
annual salaries in some cases
the pension system is in so much trouble
French president Emmanuel macron
declared Thursday workers would have to
work an additional two years before
government pensions could kick in
that unilateral declaration by the
president bypassing the country's
Parliament set off rioting
the country's powerful union workers
pushed back leaving garbage heaped on
streets literally adding fuel to the
already fiery situation
French prime minister Elizabeth born
faced a skeptical French Parliament
Thursday saying we cannot bet on the
future of our pensions this reform is
necessary but even with political allies
president macronas in the gravest
challenge since he was elected in 2017.
his opponents in Parliament filed a
no-confidence motion Friday saying
cutting them out of the process was
dangerous to our democracy
and a no-confidence motion will be
debated tomorrow and could come to a
vote Monday if it fails the pension bill
becomes law but if it succeeds it would
force the government to resign Michelle
Michael George thank you